Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Du, ich würde mir gerne mal so eine schöne Herrenhandtasche von Gucci kaufen, aber es ist so teuer.
Da habe ich was für dich.
Logbuch, Netzpolitik, Nummer 492 vom Vatertag.
Vom Tag der Heirenhandtasche.
Da möchte man doch gleich shoppen gehen, aber hat alles zu. So,
ja, kann ich nur noch online kaufen, weil die Läden dicht haben. Das ist das Problem.
Deutschland ist einfach umsatzfeindlich, da läuft nichts.
Kann ich nicht jetzt hier einfach so im freien Tag nutzen und einfach mal in
die Shopping-Mall latschen. Nix da.
Ich habe in letzter Zeit, nicht nur ich, sondern auch unser Sendungsgast,
den wir noch nicht vorgestellt haben, haben verwechselt in der Vorbereitung auf diesen Tag,
dass heute Vatertag ist und nicht Frauentag.
Und das ist ja ein total dummer Versprecher, wenn du sagst, ja,
dann ist ja Frauentag, ach nee, Vatertag, was so die beiden,
ich glaube, so die komplette kulturelle Gegensätze sind.
Kampftag der Frau und Bollerwagen-Sauftag zu verwechseln ist halt einfach.
Ist das nicht eigentlich Christi Himmelfahrt?
Christi Himmelfahrt, ja, das ist Christi Himmelfahrt.
Warum ist denn das Vatertag?
Ach, ich weiß auch nicht. Also die meisten Väter sagen, seitdem ich Vater bin,
war ich nicht mehr mit dem Bollerwagen saufen.
Im Osten übrigens, also meine Potsdamer Freunde sagen eher Herrentag.
Also die versuchen dem Ganzen noch irgendwie so eine gewisse Niveau drin zu halten.
Niveau? Herrentag?
Das ist doch alles schon kolonial verbrämt. Oh, oh.
Ganz gefährliches Terrain. Auf jeden Fall.
Es ist der Tag am Boller. Es ist Feiertag.
Also kann man glaube ich, die Läden haben zu. Und wenn ich jetzt meine Gucci-Herren-Tasche
kaufen würde, dann muss ich das online machen.
Da habe ich ganz viele tolle Sachen gesehen.
Aber online ist auch billiger.
Ja, richtig mit Prozenten und so.
Ach ja. Ja, jetzt sagen wir erstmal Hallo. Hallo, Herr Torkel.
Herzlich Willkommen. Du warst ja schon mal da bei uns.
Das war, welches LNP war das noch gleich?
Das war 422 Bundesverdienstcoin, hieß es da.
Und da hast du schon über Hackereien berichtet. Kleiner Spoiler,
das machen wir heute auch wieder. Deswegen bist du hier.
Wir berichten heute über Obtainereien.
Erklären wir später.
Okay, Obtainereien, wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall.
Ich würde es mal als...
Data Harvesting bezeichnen. Gibt es den Begriff schon?
Oder können wir vielleicht auch mal selber einen Fachbegriff hier so freuen?
Ich greife ein bisschen vor. Das Ganze wurde ja sehr groß und die Tabelle,
wo wir organisiert haben, heißt irgendwas Harvest-Tabelle.
Insofern liege ich schon richtig. Alles klar, sehr gut.
Die Bundesverdienst-Coin-Folge, wir haben über mehrere Hacks gesprochen,
unter anderem, dass du diese Münze hast von der Bundeswehr,
die mich immer wieder, das bringe ich in Gesprächen öfter an,
aber dieser Bundesverdienst-Coin war ja die Münze von der Bundeswehr,
weil du bei der Bundeswehr mehrere Schwachstellen gemeldet hast und dann hast du eine Münze gekriegt.
Mit der man nicht bezahlen kann.
Eine Ehrenmünze, ne?
Eine Ehrenmünze. Man kommt damit auch nicht bei der Bundeswehr rein.
Am Band.
Bei der Bundeswehr brauchst du auch keine Münze, um irgendwo reinzukommen.
Da musst du die URL richtig raten. Dann bist du schon voll dabei im Inner Circle.
Genau.
Nachdem du bei uns in der Sendung warst, war glaube ich eure Forschung zur Biometrie
in Afghanistan, die war danach, oder?
Die haben wir nur behandelt, aber warst du dazu nochmal in der Sendung?
Nee, war ich nicht, aber auch wieder ein Datenleck, also immer nur Datenlecks.
Da ging es um die Biometriegeräte, also wir haben es hier behandelt,
die Biometriegeräte, die das US-Militär in Afghanistan zurückgelassen hat,
die die Datenbank mit den,
biometrischen Daten auf den Geräten hatten und die fand man dann auf Ebay.
Und findet man weiterhin auf Ebay.
Also ich habe meine Geräte damals ja zurückgegeben, weil da so ein Special Agent
freundlich gefragt hat und wenn ein Special Agent einen freundlich fragt,
dann sagt man ja gerne und dann hatte ich zwei leere, schöne,
große Koffer zu Hause, wo Biometriegeräte reinpassen.
Und dann habe ich noch eins gekauft, ja. Ja.
Aber das war ja auch geil. Der war sechs Monate später.
Das war irgendwie sechs Monate nach eurem Vortrag, dass er euch gebeten hat,
die doch mal zu schicken, weil sie es jetzt doch untersuchen.
Da war es schon ungefähr ein Jahr her, dass ihr Bescheid gesagt habt oder dreiviertel Jahr.
Mindestens, ja.
Und dann sind die Dinger ja zurückgekommen, weil die die nicht aus der Packstation abgeholt haben.
Leider war.
Geil. Also US-Militär kann auch
noch nicht mal irgendwie ein Paket sich zuschicken lassen und abholen.
Also da sind die, zumindest in Deutschland, sehr deutsch.
Sie hatten ehrlicherweise auch angeboten, dass sie mich in Hamburg besuchen kommen.
Nee, nee, ich krieg euch das mit der Post.
Er hat uns gebeten, ob ich ihm das geben kann.
Er würde mich auch zu Hause besuchen. Voll freundliche Bitte.
So, dann habt ihr zusammen aber auch noch auf dem Camp einen Vortrag gemacht, auf dem letzten.
Genau das waren Dominik Kantorkel und ich über die Obtainerei bei unterschiedlichen
Gruppierungen aus dem Ransomware-Umfeld.
Da hatten wir ja auch einen Threat-Actor infiltriert, der offenbar Ransomware ausgerollt hat.
Wir haben auch ein bisschen über die Disclosure-Sachen gesprochen, die du gemacht hattest.
Disclosure, Hack und Back hieß der Vortrag.
Was ist denn Threat-Actor wieder für ein merkwürdiger Begriff?
Ein Bedrohungsschauspieler.
Nee, also Actor ist nicht nur Schauspieler, sondern auch Ich weiß.
Ein Akteur, genau. Bedrohlicher Akteur.
Also ein Threat Actor ist eine benennbare Gruppierung oder Person,
die Häckereien, Obtainereien macht.
Also beispielsweise was weiß ich, APT 28, den,
dass er der City wieder unterstellt wird, sie hätten die SPD mit einem Outlook-O-Day
aufgemacht und nichts Besseres zu tun gehabt, als die E-Mails von Kevin Kühner zu lesen.
Aber in dem Fall, der war glaube ich für Bian Lian, die Ransomware-Gang, aktiv.
Sorry, habe ich Threat-Actor gesagt. Über den haben wir ja Threat-Intelligence
gesammelt. Threat-Intell.
Ich meine, jede Branche hat so ihre eigene Sprache. Das ist ja vollkommen klar.
Aber ich finde das dann teilweise ganz unterhaltsam, wie hier die einzelnen
Rollen so modelliert werden.
Aber wenn wir in dem Kontext sind, dann würde ich vielleicht noch gerade ganz
kurz was empfehlen, weil dieser Vortrag, ich habe das ja danach jetzt für eine Trilogie,
postwendend, nee, danach, was sagt man dann? Nicht posthum?
Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, worum. Faktische Vortrag.
Also ich habe ja den Hirnehacken 2.0 mit Kai Biermann gehalten,
den Vortrag beim Kongress, beim aktuellen Kongress, wo wir über Ransomware-Verhandlungen
und die Threat-Actor gesprochen haben, die unterschiedlichen.
Außerdem hat der Tobias Müller den Vortrag gehalten über den Decryptor für Blackbuster.
Blackbuster ist auch eine Ransomware-Gang.
Und dann hatten wir diesen Disclosure Hack und Back und das war so eine Serie
über man setzt sich mit den Threat-Actors auseinander, bereist,
besucht mal deren Systeme,
obtaint und geht wieder.
Man obtaint. Also ich stelle einfach fest, wenn irgendwo Daten raustropfen im
Netz, dann kommst du, also bist du so eine Art Datenkleppner.
Die tropfen irgendwie immer dem Cantorkel in die Hand.
Ja, so ein Datenkleppner. Guck mal hier, da tropfen die Bits irgendwie raus.
Ruf mal den Cantorkel, der macht das wieder zu.
Daten sind ja das neue Öl und Cantorkel hat ölverschwierte Hände.
Okay, bevor wir jetzt hier lost in Association sind, Machen wir vielleicht erstmal
eine kleine Feedback-Runde, bevor es hier ins Eingemachte geht.
Was hältst du denn davon?
Ja, genau. Wir haben Feedback bekommen. Sehr viel Feedback.
Unsere Einlassungen zu Humor haben zu einigen humorvollen Kommentaren geführt
und einigen weniger humorvollen.
Die könnt ihr gerne nachlesen. Ich denke, die demonstrieren in der Breite die
Kommentare sehr gut, worüber wir gesprochen haben.
Wir haben in der letzten Folge auch darüber gesprochen,
dass unsere Freunde aus Österreich, die Organisation Neub,
ja mit Datenschutzrecht Beschwerden über OpenAI macht, spezifisch,
weil dort Geburtsdaten falsch wiedergegeben werden.
Und dazu kommentiert Wiebke.
Angriff nimmt. LLM speichern allerdings keine vollständigen Datensätze mit personenbezogenen Daten.
Da steht also nicht, Tim Pridloff ist am so und sovielten geboren.
Was ja sehr schön bei der letzten Folge, was tatsächlich falsch war.
Hast du jetzt auch verklagt, oder?
Ich hab nochmal kurz nachgeschaut. Mittlerweile habe ich am 6. Dezember Geburtstag.
Das ist eigentlich geil, so mehrmals im Jahr.
Ja, das ist eigentlich sehr gut. Dann kann man mir auch häufiger was schenken.
Kann man online was für dich bestellen. Tim Prillaf ist am Sohn zu schicken geboren.
Stattdessen werden einzelne Tokens gespeichert, die nicht zwangsläufig ganze Wörter sein müssen.
Wie LLMs Sätze in Tokens runterbrechen, wissen meines Wissens selbst die Programmierer nicht.
Zudem wird gewichtet, wie wahrscheinlich bestimmte Tokens in der Nähe voneinander auftreten.
Diese Kombinationen aus Tokens und Wahrscheinlichkeiten sind an sich keine personenbezogene Daten.
Aus ihnen lassen sich über personenbezogene Daten mit einer gewissen Genauigkeit
oder Fehlerhaftigkeit rekonstruieren.
Das wird eine Herausforderung für die Richterinnen, denn nun ist doch die Frage,
ob die DSGVO überhaupt anwendbar ist.
Eine weitere Herausforderung wird, dass bei der Verarbeitung von personenbezogenen
Daten ihre Korrektheit sichergestellt werden muss. Auch das steht in der DSGVO.
Ein halluzinierendes LLM ist da nicht vorgesehen.
Das könnte man eigentlich grundsätzlich sagen, sondern einfach nicht vorgesehen.
Hinsichtlich der DSGVO spielt übrigens keine Rolle, ob die genutzten Daten auf
Webseiten öffentlich verfügbar sind oder nicht sobald sie gesammelt oder verarbeitet
werden handelt es sich um eine Verarbeitung,
für die ein Rechtsfertigungsgrund benötigt wird. Bei LLMs ist das das berechtigte
Interesse der Anbieter, also OpenAI und Co.
Wie bereits von anderen angemerkt, muss dafür eine Abwägung zwischen den Interessen
der Betroffenen und den Verarbeitenden stattfinden.
Ob die Daten in LLM in Binärcode oder menschenlesbarem Format gespeichert sind,
ist ebenfalls unerheblich.
Es ist möglich, menschenlesbare Daten hineinzugeben und auch wieder herauszuholen.
Das Speicherformat wird bei den TUM, technischen und organisatorischen Maßnahmen, relevant.
Es hat aber keinen Einfluss darauf, ob die Verarbeitung erlaubt ist.
Wiebke, ich glaube, du bist juristisch gebildet Nein,
aber es ist ja sehr gut wiedergegeben und bevor jetzt bevor wir jetzt wieder
Kommentare bekommen weil in den drei Sätzen von Wiebke die,
Funktionalität eines LLM nicht 100% in allen Details wiedergegeben wurde können
wir nochmal es gab da so einen sehr guten Vortrag beim Kongress von einer,
Forscherin in dem Bereich. Mir fällt gerade ihr Name nicht ein,
aber den nehmen wir mit in die Shownotes auf.
Zu LLMs?
Ja, wie neuronale Netzwerke funktionieren. Der hat das sehr schön gemacht.
Da werden sich auch sicherlich Leute drüber aufregen, aber den verlinken wir nochmal.
Lass mal das Innere eines neuronalen Netzes ansehen von Annika Röll, meinst du, ne?
Ja, der war super. Den verlinken wir nochmal für Leute, die sich darüber aufregen. Zum gleichen Thema.
Stefan Tesing sagte zu eurer Diskussion über Datenschutz und LLMs.
Ich meine, wie fast immer, wenn ihr euch nicht einig seid, mal wieder beobachtet
zu haben, dass ihr auf zwei verschiedenen Ebenen argumentiert habt.
Linus-Argumente bewegen sich im Wesentlichen auf der ersten Ebene.
Ich würde sagen, auf der oberen Ebene.
Auf der Meta-Ebene oder was? Nee, die Meta-Ebene gehört dir.
Okay, ist in Ordnung. Ich bin auf der ersten Ebene, du bist auf der Meta-Ebene.
Wenn Technologiebedingungen verändert, hören Gesetze selbstverständlich nicht auf zu gelten.
Tim argumentiert eher auf der Meta-Ebene, auf welche Weise Gesetz und Verortungsgeber,
rechtliche Regeln den neuen Gegebenheiten anpassen sollten.
Auf dieser zweiten Ebene ist natürlich mehr los.
Sinnvoll ist es hierbei, sich Gedanken darüber zu machen, welche Interessen
der Allgemeinheit das ursprüngliche Gesetz schützen sollte, um es dann entsprechend zu reformieren.
Das geht gerne mal schief, hatte Wiebke ja auch gesagt. Das Urheberinnenrecht
wurde ursprünglich eingeführt, um Autorinnen vor der Ausbeutung durch jene zu
schützen, die eine Druckerpresse besitzen.
Das Interesse der Allgemeinheit war, wenn Autorinnen vor Ausbeutung geschützt
sind, bekommen wir mehr Werke.
Als das Internet um die Ecke kam, wurden die rechtlichen Regeln leider nicht so reformiert,
dass Autorinnen und Allgemeinheit weiter vor der Ausbildung durch Verlagshäuser
und andere Rechteverwerter geschützt wurden, sondern die Geschäftsmittel der
Rechtsverwerter wurden vor den neuen Möglichkeiten geschützt,
die Autorinnen und der Allgemeinheit nun zur Verfügung standen.
Das ist, finde ich, eine sehr gute Zusammenfassung.
Hat natürlich gerade mit dem Thema, zu dem Stefan sich hier äußern wollte,
überhaupt nichts zu tun, weil wir ja eigentlich über Datenschutz sprechen. Aber gut, gut Stefan.
Regelungen zum Datenschutz sowie einzelne Regelungen wie das Recht am eigenen
Bild sind dazu ersonnen worden,
die allgemeinen Persönlichkeitsrechte der Bürgerinnen vor unangemessenen staatlichen
Maßnahmen sowie ökonomischer Ausbeutung zu schützen.
Anpassungen der rechtlichen Regelungen sollten daran gemessen werden,
inwiefern sie diesen Zielen dienen.
Ihr kamt ja aber auf das Thema über die Frage, wie die Klage von Neub zu bewerten ist.
Hier kann man meines Erachtens festhalten, dass sie auf der ersten Ebene klagen,
um auf der zweiten Ebene sinnvolle Änderungen zu erzwingen, bevor Gesetz und
Verordnungsgeber das geltende Recht so verschlimmbessern, wie es Anfang der
2000er mit dem Urheberrecht geschehen ist.
Ja, finde ich eine super Perspektive.
Ich kann dem folgen,
Ich glaube es war immer noch, dass man den LLMs nicht so vorwerfen kann,
dass sie konkret persönliche Daten speichern, weil sie das ja so konkret nicht
tun. Aber das sagt ja Wiebke.
Verarbeiten, dann geben die ja wieder auf, die die jetzt speichern,
dann ist das eigentlich unerheblich.
Ja gut, verarbeiten ist ja in dem Moment dann auch eine sehr allgemeine Bezeichnung
für, wir nehmen die Daten einmal und schmeißen sie irgendwo gegen die Wand.
So, das ist dann sozusagen schon Verarbeitung. Da kann man sich natürlich dann
jetzt auch über diesen Begriff etwas streiten, ob das schon ausreichend verarbeitend
ist, weil man könnte fast argumentieren,
dass sie sich die Daten ja noch nicht mal richtig anschauen.
Also sie reißen das ja irgendwie nur so aus Zeichenketten irgendwie,
also die Daten werden nicht als solche genommen,
also sie werden nicht als Datum genommen und dann irgendwie in das System gebracht,
sondern einfach nur so als Zeichenketten und dann wie gesagt einfach an die
Wand geschmissen und am Ende ist das Muster, was die ganzen Farbkleckse ergeben,
das ist dann sozusagen die Nahrung, von der sich dieses System ändert.
Du freust dich ja nur, dass du jetzt mehrmals im Jahr random Geburtslust-Geschränke bekommst.
Deswegen verteidige ich das jetzt hier auch so massiv. Mal gucken, wie es funktioniert.
Kein Talk, wie siehst du das? Diese Klage von, oder überhaupt den KI-Fluch oder Segen?
Beides. Ich würde ein anderes Beispiel nehmen.
Also LLMs, ja, ich kann eure beiden Ebenen, glaube ich, nachvollziehen.
Ich möchte jetzt LLMs auch nicht einfach abschalten.
Gleichzeitig ist es bei Gesichtserkennung zum Beispiel auch so,
dass sich Unternehmen da jetzt irgendwie KI bedienen und so Gesichter-Suchmaschinen bauen.
Und die crawlen das gesamte Internet, suchen alle Bilder zusammen und zack,
ich kann ein Foto von dir machen.
Und die Suchmaschine sagt mir, wo du im Internet überall auftauchst.
Ein Unternehmen, das das macht, ist PimEyes.
Und dadurch wird dann halt einfach mal Anonymität da draußen beendet und da
ist dann auch die Frage, ist die DSGVO anwendbar?
Und viele Leute sagen ganz klar, ja, die DSGVO ist anwendbar,
denn da werden eben nicht nur irgendwie Daten zusammengesucht und dann kommen
da komische Zeichenketten raus,
sondern es werden personenbezogene Daten verarbeitet und das Ganze ohne meine Zustimmung.
Also da würde ich dir auch voll zustimmen und das ist auch ein gutes Beispiel
für, wo die Daten ja explizit als solche in das System eingeführt werden.
Also es wird ja explizit ein Bild von einem Gesicht gesucht und als solches abgespeichert.
Es wird dann KI-Methoden für den Vergleich, für die Suche verwendet.
Aber speichern die wirklich die Bilder alle?
Naja, sie werfen das dann halt in ihr Model, um darin zu suchen.
Aber in dem Moment, wo sie die Daten aus dem Netz extrahieren,
extrahieren sie ja explizit ein Gesicht.
Und auch in dem Moment, wo sie die Anfrage des Nutzers bedienen,
liefern sie auch explizit genau das.
Das ist mit diesem Geburtsdatum auf beiden Seiten nicht der Fall,
sondern es ist eher ein Zufall.
Es ist eher so, ob du im Gesicht noch so einen herbeihalluzinierten Pickel hast oder nicht.
Ja, ich meine, es ist so, als ob du nach einem Gesicht suchst und dann kriegst
du irgendwie einen 3D-Modellplan vom Spielzeugauto oder sowas.
Also klar, es bleibt schwierig hier mit der Definition, aber das sind für mich
zwei Beispiele, wo ich eher sagen würde, daran kann man schon auch klar machen,
was das eine ist und wo die DSGVO auf jeden Fall greifen sollte.
Also bei Pim A ist ich voll dabei, aber halt bei diesen allgemeinen LLMs eher nicht. Naja.
Okay, aber die Folge scheint mir die gleiche zu sein.
Aber okay, man könnte argumentieren, dass ein falsches Geburtsdatum im Zweifelsfall zu Vorteilen führt.
Rentnerrabatte, Geschenke.
Dann komme ich aber nicht in meinen Film mehr rein, weil sie sagen,
sorry, aber du bist ja noch Kinder 18.
Die Frage ist doch so ein bisschen, haben wir noch personenbezogene Daten?
Also klar, ich verarbeite personenbezogene Daten, wenn ich das Modell baue.
Da ist dann vielleicht auch die Frage, durfte zum Bau des Modells schon dein
Geburtsdatum genutzt werden? Und dann ist die zweite Frage, wenn ich dieses
Modell benutze, kommen da personenbezogene Daten raus?
Wenn da dein Name rauskommt, so dann irgendwie schon.
Wenn da zufällig jedes Mal ein anderes Geburtsdatum rauskommt,
dann ist das Geburtsdatum wahrscheinlich nicht so richtig personenbezogen mehr.
Und ich glaube, der Hebel, den Neub da ja jetzt nutzt, ist das Recht auf Korrektur
auch und nicht nur auf Löschung.
Also Löschung und Korrektur, die nehmen auf jeden Fall alle recht in Anspruch.
Genau, also es kann jedenfalls sein, dass keine personenbezogenen Daten mehr
da sind, weil ich keine sinnvollen personenbezogenen Daten mehr aus diesem LLM rauskriege.
Aber es gibt sicherlich Gegenbeispiele, wo ich für eine Person dann diverse
personenbezogene Daten kriege und das ist dann für die einzelne Person vielleicht schlecht.
Ich meine, bei den LLMs ist es ja so, wenn du halbwegs zuverlässige Daten bekommst,
also die eine hohe Wahrscheinlichkeit haben, dass sie auch stimmen, dann,
weil mehr oder weniger das ganze Internet diese Informationen an sehr vielen
Orten ohnehin bereithält.
Und dann ist es halt immer schwierig.
Darf ich das Geburtsdatum von Thomas Gottschalk der Welt verkünden? Die Welt weiß das schon.
Das ist halt einfach kein Geheimnis mehr in dem Sinne.
Wann hattest du jetzt laut ChatGPT Geburtstag?
Heute oder letztes Mal?
Letztes Mal. Weil jetzt hast du am 18. November Geburtstag.
Das war jetzt 6. Dezember.
6. Dezember.
Und letztes Mal war es glaube ich irgendwo im Oktober, ich schaue mal kurz, 2.
Oktober, aber immerhin, jetzt als ich das eben nochmal gefragt habe,
wurde ich auch explizit,
Nicht nur mit Tim Pridloff hat am 6. Dezember Geburtstag, sondern die Antwort
lautet Tim Pridloff, der deutsche Podcaster und Medienkünstler.
Hat am 18. November Geburtstag gesagt.
Ja, am 6.
Aber ist schon mal klar, also ich bin der, der deutsche Podcaster.
Hat Chat-GBT auch extra unterstrichen.
Bold.
Aber wirst du jemals wieder Geburtstag haben oder wirst du immer wieder vertröstet werden?
Das habe ich nie mehr Geburtstag, das ist toll Das heißt, ich werde nicht mehr älter,
Wenn ich Geburtstag habe, kann man nie älter.
Werden Du wirst jetzt einfach weiter vertröstet Ich gratuliere dir nie wieder Ich bleibe.
Einfach immer forever 23.
Mein Lieblingskommentar war zur Bezahlkarte von Lipfi Ich versuche das mal auch
so mit der richtigen Intonation zu behandeln.
Wir hatten ja darüber gesprochen, dass die Bezahlkarte an Geflüchtete ausgegeben
werden soll, mit dem erklärten Ziel zu verhindern, dass diese Bargeld haben.
Wir haben den Sinn dieses Ziels ohnehin schon in Frage gestellt.
Lipfi schreibt nun, Bezahlkarte ist super dumm, kaufst halt einfach Klamotten,
gibst sie instants zurück, weil sie nicht passen, bam, Bargeld.
Und jetzt, die glauben Wir glauben echt, dass Menschen, die durch die Hölle
gegangen sind, sowas juckt.
Ich glaube, damit ist das Thema auch abschließend erörtert.
Bäm, Bargeld. Oder verkaufst du die Leute.
Es ist wirklich relativ unwahrscheinlich, dass es Leuten gelingt,
Leute von Bargeld fernzuhalten.
Also wenn sie das unbedingt haben wollen, dann wird das auch mit einer Bezahlkarte
funktionieren. Das kann man glaube ich so festhalten.
Ich möchte im Kontext der Bezahlkarten, weil die jetzt natürlich auch aus IT-Sicherheitssicht
untersucht werden, einen Responsible Disclosure anregen, falls da was Interessantes gefunden wird.
Also Responsible Disclosure heißt, ich informiere die Betroffenen über die Sicherheitslücke,
damit die dann entsprechend damit umgehen können.
Die Betroffenen von den Bezahlkarten sind die Geflüchteten.
Und wenn ich zum Beispiel eine Lücke finde, die es mir in Bayern erlaubt,
auch außerhalb meiner Region einzukaufen oder auch mehr als 50 Euro im Monat
auszugeben, dann erzähle ich das bitte den Geflüchteten.
Ja, vielleicht wird das noch Bezahlkartefluch oder Segen, ja Vielleicht können
die sich damit dann doch mal eine Existenz aufbauen,
Okay Dann, damit wären wir, glaube ich, bei unserem Hauptthema oder wollen wir
noch über die Gamescom vorher sprechen Warst du schon mal bei der Gamescom?
Bisher nicht Ich auch nicht. Tim, warst du mal bei der Gamescom?
Nee.
Ist in Köln, ne? Ja Computerspielmesse.
Mittlerweile ist es in Köln. War das vorher? Leipzig war es glaube ich mal und
dann ist es in den Westen abgewandert.
Da gibt es Diskussionen über ein Datenleck oder wie muss ich mir das vorstellen?
Jemand hat IT-Sicherheitsforschung betrieben.
Laut Twitter und Medienberichten wurde eine Lücke gefunden und auch das entsprechend
in Richtung Köln Messe und oder Gamescom kommuniziert.
Ähm, Köln-Messe wiederum hat das Vorhandensein einer Sicherheitslücke dementiert
und die sicherheitsforschende Person bekam Post, wenn ich das richtig verstanden
habe, von der Staatsanwaltschaft.
Mit dem Vorwurf, sie hätte ein Datenleck obtained oder mit der Behauptung,
sie hätte etwas Falsches gesagt?
Ja, da wurde einer der Hacker-Paragraphen, glaube ich, rausgeholt.
Und meinst du, die Daten sind noch im Internet?
Ich habe wenig Einblicke in Bezug auf das Slack, was diese Person gefunden hat.
Aber zwei Freunde und ich haben uns das natürlich auch angeschaut und geguckt,
sind die Daten bei der Gamescom oder bei der Köln-Messe sicher?
Und wir sind auch über ein Datenleck gestolpert.
Details kann ich jetzt nicht sagen, weil da einfach auch personenbezogene Daten
betroffen sind, wie Namen, Vornamen, Nachnamen, E-Mail-Adressen,
Telefonnummern von einigen hundert bis tausend Leuten immerhin.
Geburtsdaten?
Ich glaube teilweise ja.
Gib die mal chat, GPT.
Jedenfalls haben wir eben gehört, dass dieser andere Sicherheitsforscher eine
Anzeige kassiert hat insofern haben wir jetzt Angst und trauen uns nicht zu melden.
Das ist natürlich schade für die Gamescom und ihre betroffenen Personen.
Ja
Und somit wären wir beim nächsten Datenleak und zwar hast du seit längerer Zeit
mit mehreren Leuten, die nicht alle genannt werden wollen,
dich mit einer Online-Shop-Infrastruktur auseinandergesetzt.
Und ich erinnere mich, dass wir nach unserem Camp-Vortrag, also irgendwie im
August, haben wir mit Kai Biermann von Zeit Online gesprochen,
also glaub du kurz, ich danach noch ein bisschen länger und danach irgendwie
ein bisschen gesprochen und diese Daten, auf die du da Zugriff hattest,
oder diese Systeme, die du da gesehen hattest, sorry,
das hatten wir eigentlich schon wieder weggelegt.
Und dann sagte Kai, weil irgendwie war unklar, was diese Online-Shop-Infrastruktur
macht und wofür es die gibt.
Und Kai sagte dann so, oh, das interessiert mich aber sehr, weil meine Tochter
wollte Doc Martens bestellen im Internet, nur 40 Euro, Papa.
Und hat dann für 40 Euro Doc Martens bestellt und hat auch genau so viel Doc
Martens bekommen, wie man für 40 Euro kriegen kann, nämlich keine.
Und es war so ein bisschen wie, dass irgendwie so langsam klar wurde,
okay, krass, vielleicht,
deswegen will jemand viele Online-Shops haben.
Ja, also in Bezug auf Datenlecks tritt einfach ein krasser Gewöhnungseffekt
ein und das hilft, wenn dann zum Beispiel ein Kai ankommt und nochmal seine
Sicht der Dinge dazugibt.
Also deutlich vor dem Camp waren wir schon über einen Datenleck gestolpert.
Damit ging es los und dieses Datenleck hat ein bisschen zur Infrastruktur eines Webshops erzielt.
Aber dieses eine Datenleck führte dann zu vielen anderen Datenlecks So dass
wir dann plötzlich einige 10.000, nein nicht einige 10.000, zu dem Zeitpunkt
etwa 10.000 Webshops vor uns hatten,
die alle das gleiche Framework nutzten, die alle ein ähnliches Datenleck hatten
und wir wussten nicht so richtig,
Was soll das? Also sind das jetzt einfach Webshops, die günstig irgendwelchen Ramsch verkaufen?
Wird da geliefert oder wird einfach nicht geliefert?
Wir hatten dann selbst mal bestellt mit einer sogenannten Canary Kreditkarte,
einer Kreditkarte, die uns benachrichtigt, wenn sie genutzt wird.
Also es ist gar keine echte Kreditkarte, wo Geld abgebucht werden kann,
sondern ich kann dann noch eine zweite URL beim Konfigurieren dieser Canary-Kreditkarte
angeben und darüber kann ich eine Benachrichtigung triggern,
wenn jemand diese Karte versucht zu nutzen.
Aber dann würde sozusagen die Bezahlung abgelehnt werden, aber man weiß zumindest,
dass sie jetzt auch konkret benutzt wurde.
Genau.
Wo kriegt man sowas her?
Gibt es im Internet. nett.
Also ich meine, das ist ein Produkt oder das bieten Banken an oder ist das jetzt
für Security-Forscher oder was?
Ich glaube, das bietet ja eine Forschungsgruppe an, damit Dritte das nutzen.
Und die ist dafür da, dass du, keine Ahnung, die in deine beispielsweise in
deinen Daten hast und weißt, okay, wenn da jemand darauf zugreift,
habe ich einen Daten- Data-Case oder in dem Fall mal gucken,
was noch mit der Kreditkarte passiert, mal gucken, ob die wirklich von wem da
zugegriffen wird oder sonst was.
Genau.
Ganz praktisches Ding.
Mit genau so einer Karte haben wir dann bestellt und dann ist einfach nichts passiert.
Aber die zahlt ja auch nicht, diese Kreditkarte dann, oder?
Genau, aber wir hätten ja merken müssen, wenn da jemand versucht,
was abzubuchen und das ist auch nicht passiert, beziehungsweise wir haben es nicht bemerkt.
Vergessen zu gucken, oder?
Irgendwas war in der Meldekette kaputt, deswegen haben wir es nicht bemerkt
und auch dank Kai wurden wir dann doch wieder motiviert, diese Webshops uns anzuschauen.
Ja, und das Ganze ist dann in den letzten Monaten sehr eskaliert.
Ich erzähle jetzt erstmal das Ergebnis, wo wir dann zum Schluss angekommen sind
und dann können wir nochmal drüber sprechen, was wir noch so gelernt haben und
wie wir da hingekommen sind.
Als Ergebnis haben wir knapp 76.000 Domains diesem Fake-Shop-Netzwerk zuordnen können.
Dieses Netzwerk hat auch einen Namen bekommen, also Checklist in meinem Lebenslauf.
Ich habe ein Fraud-Netzwerk benannt. Wir nennen es Bogus Bazaar.
Diese Webshops bieten günstige, aber nicht zu günstige Produkte an.
Von Dior, Nike, Hugo Boss, Versace, Prada und andere.
In der Regel sind die Produkte aber so zwischen 50 und 100 Euro teuer.
Im Schnitt werden die glaube ich für 77 Euro verkauft.
Das heißt die Preise liegen so bei
75 Prozent von dem, was man an anderen richtigen Shops erwarten könnte.
Pi mal Daumen.
Okay, gut. Nur um so ein Gefühl dafür zu bekommen, was du meinst mit nicht zu billig.
Also gerade noch glaubwürdig, aber auch irgendwie so ein Betrag, wo...
Wo man sagt, das lohnt sich. Genau.
Und wo du im Zweifelsfall als geprellte Person sagst, wie viel Aufwand mache ich jetzt für 40 Euro?
Wie viel Aufwand mache ich für 70?
Für so ein bisschen...
Also vermutlich wirst du nicht so viel Zeit investieren, weil du erkennst,
dass du jetzt nur noch den Schaden erhöhst.
Genau, also es sind keine teuren Fernseher für mehrere tausend Euro und es ist
auch nicht so, dass dort 150 Euro teure Schuhe für 20 Euro angeboten werden,
sondern es scheint schon irgendwie ein gutes, gerade noch so glaubwürdiges Angebot zu sein. Nein.
Diese Webshops sind und waren in diversen Sprachen verfügbar,
also nicht nur auf Deutsch, sondern auch Englisch, Französisch,
Spanisch, Schwedisch, Italienisch, kein Chinesisch.
Wir haben zufällig E-Mail-Adressen von über 850.000 Personen gesehen,
fast eine halbe Million Kreditkartendaten inklusive Gültigkeitsdatum und CVC-Code.
Also vollständig anwendbar, vollständig nutzbar. Wie haben die die gesammelt?
Im Bestellprozess werden die Kreditkartendaten ein bis zweimal abgerufen.
Wir können gerne einmal durch den Bestellprozess. Genau, machen wir gleich eine
Daten von mehr als einer Million Bestellungen in den letzten drei Jahren gesehen.
Das Bestellvolumen beträgt deutlich über 50 Millionen Euro, wobei wir dazu auch
sagen müssen, viele dieser Bestellungen sind gar nicht komplett durchgegangen.
Da wurde nicht direkt Geld abgebucht und in erster Linie waren nur die Daten
weg. Aber wir wissen nicht, was im Hintergrund dann zusätzlich mit diesen Daten noch passiert.
Also Kreditkartendaten sind auf jeden Fall oft abgeflossen und es kann natürlich
sein, dass ein halbes Jahr später dann noch versucht wird, diese Kreditkartendaten zu nutzen.
Gab's da auch so Apple Pay oder sowas, so Online, so solche Bezahlungen,
das lief teilweise über Stripe.
Ne?
Ich bin nicht ganz sicher.
Ob es Apple, ist da auch Apple Pay betroffen?
Ich frage mich, ob du jetzt Kreditkartennummer erfassen und gib mir noch deinen
3-Nummern-Code und ich speichere das ab. Das ist ja das eine.
Das andere ist, ob du wirklich auch eine reale, von Third-Party geleitete Transaktion hast.
Aber ich glaube, da war auch Stripe teilweise mit im Spiel und Paypal.
Also da ist schon auch echtes Processing gelaufen. Genau.
Da ist das Design dieser Gruppe nicht optimal.
Also wenn ich bestelle, muss ich einmal meine Kreditkartendaten eingeben,
klick dann auf bestellen, dann werden im Hintergrund die Daten schon wegtransportiert
und ich werde als User im Frontend auf eine zweite Seite weitergeleitet.
Das ist oft unter einer anderen Domain und da steht dann entweder bestätigt
oder teilweise auch einfach nur Bestellung abgelehnt oder ich lande bei Stripe
und darf dort nochmal meine Daten eingeben und dann ist das Geld auch weg oder ich lande bei Paypal,
darf meine Daten eingeben und das Geld ist weg.
Teilweise wird dann aber auch die Paypal-Freunde-Funktion genutzt, aber nicht immer.
Und warum, also was ist der Hintergrund, dass irgendwas abgelehnt wird?
Also wer lehnt das dann ab? Dieser Webshop selber oder irgendwelche Zahlungsdienstleister?
Meine Vermutung ist, also du korrigierst mich, also normalerweise,
wenn du jetzt in einem legitimen Online-Shop eine Order machst,
der darf deine Kreditkartendaten gar nicht annehmen und erst recht nicht speichern.
Deswegen werden die meisten dich, um die PCI-DSS-Pflichten zu umgehen,
Payment Card Industry Data Security Standard, darfst du zum Beispiel den CVC
speichern, ist schlecht. Aber,
Damit sie diese ganzen Vorgaben umgehen, gibt es diese ganzen Payment-Anbieter.
Also theoretisch könnte ja auch jeder einfach sagen, alles klar,
ich werde Kreditkarten-Anbieter.
Aber die nutzen halt dann Stripe, schicken dich da hin und Stripe regelt diesen Kram für dich.
Die sehen also diese Kreditkarten gar nicht und können damit gar nicht in Kontakt
kommen, weil du die direkt an Stripe sendest.
So wie ich das hier verstanden habe, machen die ganz einfach etwas,
was wie ein Payment-Interface aussieht, damit du deine Kreditkartendaten eingibst,
speichern die und sagen, hat nicht geklappt, probier nochmal.
Und fürs zweite Mal schicken sie dich zum richtigen Payment-Interface.
Korrekt?
Genau.
Püffig.
Ja. Ja.
PCI-DSS ist ja auch geil. So wie PCMCIA. Weißt du, was PCMCIA heißt?
PC
Micro Card Interface oder wie war das noch?
Nee, es heißt People Can't Memorize Computer Industry Acronyms.
Okay.
Aber ich glaube, es ist Card Adapter oder sowas.
Ich gucke jetzt, was das heißt. Personal Computer Memory Card International Association.
Naja.
Wenn die vor der Tür stehen, weißt du, keine Ahnung, wofür das Akronym steht.
Paymentprozess. Okay, die sammeln die Kreditkarten.
Genau, also man kann dort bestellen. Wir haben da auch bestellt und dann passiert nichts.
Teilweise wird Geld abgebucht, teilweise oder oft wird von der Karte direkt
danach, direkt nach dem Bestellen, weniger Geld, etwas weniger Geld abgebucht, als dort steht.
Ich zitiere aus einer E-Mail, die eine Kundin oder ein Kunde an diese Gruppe dann geschrieben hat.
Hallo, warum wurde meine Bestellung storniert? Nummer 416326.
Ich habe per Karte bezahlt. Hier erschien ein geringerer Betrag,
als in dem Warenkorb angezeigt wurde.
Darüber freut man sich ja zunächst, wirkt aber alles sehr suspekt.
Ich möchte die Sachen gerne doch noch haben, wenn ich aber hierfür alles von
vorne eingeben muss, verzichte ich.
Ich glaube, der hat das Brudi, die ist des Ausmaßes des Problems noch nicht ganz klar.
Als du das selber, als ihr diesen Testkauf gemacht habt mit dieser Canary-Card,
wie ist da konkret, also seid ihr da auch zu Stripe noch weitergeleitet worden?
Also hast du dann sozusagen deine Karte bei Stripe angegeben oder nur so hinterlassen?
Wir wurden damals zu PayPal weitergeleitet und dort haben wir dann keine Daten
mehr eingegeben, sondern haben dann geguckt, okay, reicht das?
Werden unsere Kreditkartendaten jetzt schon genutzt? Wir hatten jetzt keinen
PayPal-Account parat, den wir da noch verbrennen wollten.
Ah, okay, also ihr habt letztlich gar nichts bezahlt.
Genau.
Ihr habt mich verarscht.
Also keinen echten Bezahlvorgang eingeleitet.
Genau, also wir bekamen eine Bestellbestätigung, aber wir haben jetzt nicht
bei PayPal noch auf Bezahlen geklickt und wir wussten natürlich,
unsere Kreditkarte, die wir da angegeben haben, kann auch nicht wirklich Geld rausgeben.
Und ist die dann getriggert worden irgendwann?
Wir haben dann sehr, sehr viel später festgestellt, sie war doch getriggert worden und zwar ist...
Wenige Monate nach unserer Bestellung immer mal wieder versucht worden,
für einen Dollar oder einen Dollar 50 dort Geld abzubuchen.
Und das ist etwas, was relativ üblich ist.
Vielleicht hat unsere Gruppe hier unsere Kreditkartendaten gesammelt mit anderen
weitergegeben an andere Akteure in diesem kriminellen Universum.
Threat Actor.
Threat Actor, genau. Genau. Und wenn man diese Kreditkartendaten dann weiterverkaufen
möchte, wäre es gut, wenn die funktionieren.
Und um das zu testen, werden so kleine Transaktionen getriggert,
die nicht unbedingt direkt dazu führen, dass so eine Kreditkarte gesperrt wird.
Und dann, wenn man weiß, dass diese Kreditkarte funktioniert,
dann kann man sie sehr viel teurer noch weiterverkaufen.
Und genau dieses Testen haben wir dann beobachten können und über drei Monate
wurde glaube ich fünf oder sechs Mal versucht,
dann einen Dollar oder einen Dollar zehn
abzubuchen über irgendwelche Fresslieferdienste in den USA zum Beispiel.
Also angebliche Fresslieferdienste?
Ne, das waren dann schon tatsächliche Fresslieferdienste.
Also wo dann da was wiederum bestellt wurde und so, okay, verstehe.
Damit es nicht weiter auffällt. Ach ja, Rattchen.
Wie sind denn die Leute auf den Online-Shop gekommen?
Die verschiedenen Zeitungen, die dann involviert waren, das war am Ende nicht
nur die Zeit, sondern auch Guardian und Le Monde, sind auf verschiedene Leute
zugegangen, die bestellt haben, knapp 50.
Und die haben berichtet, dass vor allem über Google einfach ein Produkt gesucht
wurde und dann ist man auf der Seite gelandet und hat bestellt.
Klar, Suchmaschinen. Ich meine, du haust das einfach rein, sagst,
wo gibt es Herrenhandtasche günstig?
Und dann kommt halt herrenhandtasche24.de.
Haben die da Werbung geschaltet?
Ich weiß nicht, ob sie Werbung geschaltet haben und ein anderer üblicher Kanal
wäre Spam auf Telegram, Twitter, andere Social Media und so weiter.
Kann sein, dass diese Kanäle auch von dieser Gruppe bespielt wurden, wissen wir nicht.
Ja, oder irgendwelche TikTok-Shops oder so, da hast du ja dann mittlerweile
irgendwelche hampeligen Influencer, die dir das dann halt auch direkt in die Fresse werfen.
Wenn ich das richtig sehe, sind aber das jetzt keine oder mehrheitlich zumindest nicht jetzt neue,
wirre Domains, die irgendwie sind, genommen worden,
sondern die haben dann explizit auslaufende Domains abgewartet und aufgekauft
und dann quasi die Reputation, die diese Domains gerade noch hatten bei Google
quasi gleich mitgenutzt.
Genau, die Gruppe betreibt ein halbwegs aufwendiges Monitoring,
wo mehrere Millionen Domains drinstecken und wenn der Gruppe dann eine Domain
auffällt, die gerade frei geworden ist,
aber bei Google noch ein gutes Standing hat oder wo man bei Google noch mehr als 20 Bilder findet,
dann ist diese Domain wenigstens attraktiv für diese Gruppe und wird dann zeitnah bestellt.
Und dann deployen sie da auch relativ gut durch, automatisiert einfach einen Online-Shop.
Genau, das Ganze funktioniert sehr schön arbeitsteilig. Es wird ein Quest angelegt.
Uns unbekannte Personen kümmern sich dann darum, dass ein WordPress an der richtigen
Stelle im Internet ausgerollt wird.
Die Domain wird konfiguriert und automatisiert werden dann über CSV-Dateien
Produktdaten, Produktbilder importiert und da kamen ganz schöne Datenmengen zusammen.
Also da liegen dann einfach auch auf bestimmten Servern Terabyte von Produktbildern
rum, weil man für die vielen tausend Webshops natürlich auch viele,
viele Produktbilder benötigt.
Was meinst du mit, es wurde ein Quest angelegt?
Also Quest angelegt heißt, es wurde eine Aufgabe angelegt, die dann eine andere
Person dieses Netzwerks erledigt.
Es findet also einfach eine Aufgabenverteilung statt.
Wir haben uns noch gar nicht so sehr über dieses Netzwerk unterhalten,
das sollten wir jetzt vielleicht nachholen.
Dieses Team, dieses Netzwerk, was wir Bogus Bazaar nennen, besteht aus einem
Kernteam, das für Infrastruktur zuständig ist.
Die betreiben Server, die entwickeln die Software, die modifizieren das WordPress,
sodass sie Kreditkartendaten abfließen können und sie kümmern sich um die Payment Gateways.
Und drumherum gibt es mehrere Franchise-Nehmer, könnte man sagen.
Intern heißen sie Merchants, die diese Infrastruktur nutzen.
Und es ist vorstellbar, dass es tatsächlich Franchise-Nehmer sind,
die dann halbwegs unabhängig voneinander tausende von Webshops jeweils betreiben.
Und innerhalb dieser Merchants, innerhalb dieser Franchise-Nehmer gibt es auch
wieder eine sehr starke Aufgabenverteilung.
Es gibt dort Personen, die für Domains zuständig sind und dort neue Domains auswählen.
Es gibt Personen, die für Suchmaschinen-Optimierung zuständig sind und es gibt
auch Senior-Personen, die für Suchmaschinen-Optimierung zuständig sind.
SSEO.
SSEO, genau. Also es ist einfach eine krasse Aufgabenverteilung.
Im Backend sind mehr als 20 Rollen, Userrollen definiert.
Aber allen Teilnehmern dieses Systems ist klar, es geht ausschließlich um Fake-Webshops.
Also wenn du jetzt sagst, jemand nimmt diese Dienstleistung in Anspruch,
dann nimmt er das wohl wissend in Anspruch, dass hier sozusagen nie irgendein
Produkt verkauft werden soll, sondern dass diese ganzen Shops nur Fake sind.
Ich bin mir sehr sicher, dass das nicht alle wissen.
Dort arbeiten.
Okay, die dort arbeiten. Ich meine jetzt nicht, die dort arbeiten,
aber wenn du jetzt sagst, es gibt jetzt jemanden, der nimmt diese Infrastruktur
in Anspruch, könnte man denken,
das sind jetzt Leute, die wollen einfach einen normalen Webshop aufsetzen und
wissen gar nicht, dass da so eine Hintertür ist, verkaufen aber vielleicht tatsächlich
wirkliche Produkte, aber das ist nicht der Fall. Also niemand verkauft da wirkliche Produkte.
Sie bieten das nicht irgendwo offiziell an, wenn du sagst, ich hätte gerne einen
Webshop, sagen die nicht, geil das Offering hier, wir haben eine gute Domain, die ist...
Also es ist nur eine Rollenverteilung innerhalb Innerhalb dieses kriminellen Systems.
Korrekt, genau.
Aber Zwischenfrage, ist das so, dass Sie wirklich nie was versendet haben?
Doch, manchmal versenden sie was. Das ist, glaube ich.
Auch eine ganz schöne E-Mail-Zone.
Manche Leute haben berichtet, dass sie was bekommen und beschweren sich dann.
Zum Beispiel, ich bekam heute statt des Salomon-Rucksack eine Sonnenbrille.
Was soll das? Auf E-Mails antwortet niemand.
Oder am 15. September habe ich eine Jacke von Blutgeschwister gekauft und auch bezahlt.
Heute kam eine Sonnenbrille an. Was soll das? Wo bleibt meine Ware?
Sonst werde ich Anzeige erstatten wegen Betrugs. Bitte machen. Ja, das würde helfen.
Oder hallo, ich wollte mich mal über den aktuellen Status meiner Bestellung informieren.
Letzte Bestellung wurde anstatt des Pullis ein Ring geliefert und die aktuelle
ist schon vier Wochen in Bearbeitung.
Der hat ja noch ein zweites Mal bestellt, oder?
Ja, wir haben tatsächlich mehrere Berichte von Leuten, die mehrfach bestellt haben.
Hier offenbar auch auf der gleichen Webseite.
Aber wir können auch nachvollziehen, dass verschiedene Leute einfach auf verschiedenen
Domains bestellt haben.
Ich frage mich, warum die überhaupt noch irgendwas liefern.
Aber ich kann mir vorstellen, dass sie die Tracking-Nummern irgendwo brauchen.
Vielleicht ist es dann leichter gegenüber Kreditkartenfirmen auch zu sagen,
doch, doch, wir haben geliefert.
So Legitimität herzustellen.
Eine andere Möglichkeit, also das ist jetzt wirklich reine Spekulation,
aber es gibt teilweise auch das Interesse Fake-Bestellungen halt durchzuführen.
Aber dann bestellst du quasi bei einem legitimen Händler, bestellst den Kram
irgendwo hin, um dann nachher im Namen dieser Person ein Review zu schreiben
und zu sagen, ja geiles Produkt oder so und hier ist auch wirklich angekommen,
vertrauenswürdiger Händler, 5 Sterne.
Aber dann würden sie das Produkt auf jeden Fall im Zweifelsfall von Amazon oder
Temu oder AliExpress oder so bekommen.
Das wäre jetzt eine andere Spekulation, warum auf einmal Leute Krempel kriegen.
Das ist in den USA glaube ich ein relativ verbreitetes Phänomen,
dass Leute irgendwie so Billigstartikel aus China bekommen, weil Leute ihre
Reputation als Merchant auf einer Plattform hochtreiben wollen.
Das könnte ein anderer Grund sein, was man mit einer tatsächlichen Lieferung
in Anführungszeichen Gewinn machen kann.
Also falls es hier Leute gibt, die mithören und schon mal in diese Richtung
geforscht haben und das untersuchen wollen, wir stellen die Domains gerne zur Verfügung.
Ich frage mich, ob gegen diese, das ist ja auch wieder so eine Lücke,
finde ich, in der Art und Weise, wie so Domain-Sales und Resales funktionieren.
Dass wenn jetzt eine Domain gekündigt wird und nicht weiter fortgeführt wird,
dass es dann quasi kein Meldesystem gibt, dass man sagt, diese Domain ist jetzt
nicht mehr in Benutzung, die Besuchmaschinen liefert jetzt auch bitte keine Ergebnisse mehr.
Vielleicht gibt es so einen Mechanismus, keine Ahnung, aber in dem Fall,
da gibt es noch ein gutes Rating, kann man weiter benutzen und klar,
du hast natürlich so Archive.org und so weiter, wenn Leute da nachschauen,
sehen sie halt irgendwie, okay, da gab es mal was, aber für so Suchmaschinen,
die wollen ja eigentlich relativ aktuell sein.
Nein, das müsste meiner Meinung nach einen Mechanismus geben,
dass in dem Moment, wo die Domain gekündigt wird, der Domain-Reseller mehr oder
weniger die Suchmaschinen triggert und sagt.
Ist doch nicht doof, damit versaut er sich doch potenziell den Preis.
Ja, es sei denn, die Regeln schreiben das halt vor, dass man das zu tun hat.
Und wir könnten da ja auch unterscheiden zwischen Registrar und Domain-Reseller.
Und wenn die DENIC das anbieten würde, wenn ich selbst eine Domain habe und
die aktiv aufgeben möchte, dann kann ich glaube ich auch an Suchmaschinen noch.
Rantreten und sagen, die Liste mal meine Domain.
Oder ich kann das über die Robots.txt lösen und der Suchmaschine quasi Hausverbot erteilen.
Schwierig wird es natürlich, wenn ein Domainbesitzer einfach sein Projekt vergisst
oder jemand verstirbt oder so.
Genau, das ist nämlich, häufig werden Domains ja auch aus dem Grund aufgelöst,
weil eine Domain kostet ja nicht viel.
Und wenn du noch irgendein Interesse daran hättest, dann hältst du dir ja aufrecht.
Ich meine, ich würde vermuten, mehrere Personen hier im Raum haben einen Batzen
an Domains, die sie noch nicht mal nutzen und bis ans Ende ihres Lebens bezahlen werden.
Einmal im Jahr versuche ich so ein paar zu reduzieren und das ist dann auch
immer so, oh, ja gut, aber okay, vielleicht habe ich noch 40 Jahre Lebenserwartung,
sechs Domains weniger vielleicht. Vielleicht. Und,
aber wenn du wirklich sagst, du cancelst das Ding, du verkaufst sie auch nicht
an jemand anders, dann hast du wahrscheinlich auch einfach so ein richtiges
Scheißegal, die Domain ist jetzt weg. Fuck it.
Und mir ist auch völlig egal, was da irgendjemand anderes als nächstes drauf macht. Das halt.
Das ist vielleicht das erste Gefühl, was man dabei hat.
Kai hat mit einer Person gesprochen, das steht auch in dem Zeitartikel,
die hat unter einer der Domains irgendein Dienst angeboten.
Jedenfalls, dort war eine Webseite mit Impressum und Personen,
die in diesen Fake-Shops bestellt haben, haben sich dann an die Person aus dem
früheren Impressum gebannt.
Das heißt...
Und wollten ihre Sonnenbrille. Genau. Und, war gut?
Ja, war gut, Gut war Arbeit für die Person, insofern gehört das so ein bisschen
zur Domainhygiene für die Zukunft auch zu gucken,
dass vielleicht diverse Archive.org Dinge verschwinden, bevor man die Domain aufgibt.
Aber auch da sollte es wahrscheinlich auf Registrar-DNS-Verwaltungsebene so
eine Art Lifetime-Record geben,
dass man also wirklich so eine offizielle Meldung macht, diese Domain war im
Besitz von dieser Firma von dann bis dann,
auch um sich rechtlich da abzusichern.
Aber auch um sozusagen eine Auskunft Teil zu sein für andere Entitäten im Internet,
die das dann halt explizit befragen können und sofort wissen, okay,
alles klar, diese Domain wurde da jetzt nicht mehr geführt, dann gibt es auch
automatisch eine Karenzzeit, was weiß ich, also wenn die jetzt nicht explizit
als im Betrieb befindlich an jemand anders weiterverkauft werden,
der es weiter betreiben soll.
Weil wenn man explizit sagt, wurde aufgegeben, es gibt keine Verwendung im Sinne
der ursprünglichen Nutzung mehr, zack bumm, hier ist jetzt Ende.
Und so ein Mechanismus existiert einfach nicht.
Ja, aber auch das würde jetzt, also das ist ein grundsätzliches Problem,
wahrscheinlich nicht nur für Fake-Shops, sondern eben auch für,
oh ich habe eine Domain, die ist frei geworden, also das ist so ein grundsätzliches Problem.
Die Fake Shops würde man damit jetzt nicht komplett eindämmen.
Denn so wie es aussieht, du hast
gesagt, insgesamt haben die über 75.000 Betrieben in einem Zeitraum von?
Bisschen unklar, wenigstens seit 2015, vielleicht auch noch früher.
Mitte April waren 22.500 Domains ungefähr online.
Die haben ja dann schon auch nennenswert Infrastrukturkosten.
Aber eben offenbar auch schon 50.000 Domains verloren.
Oder aufgegeben.
Die sie mindestens für ein Jahr bezahlt haben. Das ist dann schon mal eine halbe Million weg.
Genau, über die Zeit. Und diese Shops haben sie vermutlich offline genommen,
weil sie irgendwann delistet wurden?
Oder gibt es, das wäre die Vermutung?
Vielleicht gibt es irgendwann zu viele schlechte Reviews.
In Einzelfällen haben sich vielleicht auch Registrare da irgendwie aktiv gezeigt.
Es gibt wenige Marken, die betroffen sind, die sich an dieses Fake-Shop-Netzwerk
wenden und das Netzwerk dazu auffordern, bestimmte Dinge zu unterlassen,
keine bestimmten Marken weiterhin anzubieten.
Aber im Großen und Ganzen scheint es immer...
Die können sich an die wenden? Haben die eine Adresse? Oder wie passiert das?
Auf den Fake-Shop-Webseiten gibt es in der Regel eine Kontakt-E-Mail-Adresse.
Und da gehen dann so DMCA-Complaints und andere Dinge hin.
Und darauf antworten die dann?
Nicht unbedingt. Aber das wäre ein Grund, die Domain vielleicht aufzugeben,
bevor man da Ärger bekommt.
Und ihr habt aber auch festgestellt, dass sie bestimmte Produkte kann man da nicht listen.
Ihr hattet quasi eine Blacklist an Marken.
Es gibt eine Blacklist nicht nur an Marken, sondern auch an IP-Adressen oder an bestimmten Ländern.
Das heißt, wenn du aus China kommst, dann kannst du im Frontend bestellen und
du kriegst wahrscheinlich auch eine Bestellbestätigung, aber im Backend wird
die Bestellung dann nicht weiter bearbeitet, sondern verworfen.
Und gleiches gilt auch für bestimmte teure Marken.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie man diese Marken ausspricht.
Michael Kors zum Beispiel ist eine dieser Marken auf der Blacklist oder Nintendo
ist auch auf dieser Blacklist.
Also wer muss sich an diese Blacklist halten?
Das ist eine interne Blacklist dieser Kriminellen.
Und Produkte, die auf der Blacklist sind, kann man nicht bestellen.
Und dieses Netzwerk ist ja so ein bisschen getrennt.
Kann man nicht bestellen oder nicht einstellen?
Nicht erfolgreich, in Anführungszeichen, bestellen. Wir haben ja die Trennung
zwischen Infrastruktur-Team und Merchants, Franchise-Nehmern.
Und das Infrastruktur-Team hat offenbar Zugriff auf diese Blacklist und kann
da zum Beispiel Nintendo als Blacklist definieren.
Das heißt auch wenn ein Franchise-Nehmer sich entscheidet, oh geil ich versuche
jetzt hier Gameboys zu verkaufen werden Gameboy-Bestellungen im Hintergrund,
verworfen, weil im Backend definiert ist, Nintendo geht nicht,
ist auf der Blacklist Und.
Warum sind die auf der Blacklist?
Das wissen wir nicht ich kann mir aber vorstellen, dass das einfach Marken sind,
die in der Vergangenheit schon mehr Ärger gemacht haben als andere Hm.
Okay Ich will, also das ganz China auf der Blacklist ist, liegt wahrscheinlich
daran, dass diese Gruppe in China sitzt.
Das war glaube ich auch zu großen Teilen in Kais Artikel. Dass sie schon durchaus
als Unternehmen funktioniert.
Die,
Fuzhou Chongqing Network Technology Co. Ltd.
Mit Sitz in?
Mit Sitz in Fuzhou, China.
Das ist so eine größere Stadt, so an der Küste.
40 Millionen oder so.
Wie groß sie ist. Kann ich aber kurz nachschlagen. Ja, man hat ja von den meisten
großen Chinesenstädten nichts gehört.
Aber die haben quasi dort eine,
legale Entity. Die haben dort Angestellte.
Für die kannst du arbeiten. Es gibt da gerade Ausschreibungen und wenn du so
als Webdeveloper frisch von der Uni bei denen anfangen möchtest,
die zahlen auch relativ gut. So zwischen 500 und 1000 Euro im Monat umgerechnet.
Wenn du willst, können wir dich vermitteln.
Die haben also ein richtiges Unternehmen.
Nicht irgendwie eine Bande, die irgendwo sitzt, sondern einfach eine komplette
legale Entity in China mit Angestellten und hast nicht gesehen,
die zehntausende Fake Shops betreut und fertig.
Ja, also in diesem Unternehmen ist sicherlich nicht alles organisiert,
aber ein Teil läuft über dieses Unternehmen.
Ich glaube nicht, dass die Geldzahlungen jetzt direkt über dieses Unternehmen
laufen, aber es gibt ja Aspekte beim Betrieb dieser Webshops,
die erstmal nicht illegal erscheinen.
Das Ausrollen von WordPress-Instanzen oder das Einstellen von Produkten,
das machen ja auch echte Webshops und das kann man wunderbar legal gestalten
und deswegen gehe ich auch davon aus, dass nicht alle Leute,
die hier involviert sind,
wir waren bei dem Punkt vorhin, nicht wissen, dass das Ganze hier illegal ist.
Ist ja auch super easy. Ich stelle mir das so vor, wenn du jetzt so eine Web-Developerin
bei einem Online-Shop bist,
hast du mit allem zu tun, aber sicherlich nicht mit dem Lager und sicherlich
nicht mit dem First-Level-Support der Kundinnen, die sich dort beschweren.
Das heißt, ich kann mir sehr gut vorstellen, dass du da die ganze Zeit so einen
Online-Shop pflegst, Produkte rein und guck mal hier oben links noch ein Logo
oder so und dann siehst du vielleicht auch, dass da Bestellungen eingehen und das ist alles super.
Ja nicht nur das, also die Leute, die da vermutlich arbeiten,
sehen nicht nur, dass Bestellungen eingehen, sondern in der Bestellübersicht
sind die E-Mail-Adressen auch so ein bisschen ausgegraut oder mit Sternchen
versehen, damit da die personenbezogenen Daten geschützt werden.
Das würde ich ja zum Beispiel auch potenziell erwarten als Mitarbeiterin oder
Zuarbeiterin in irgendeinem Online-Shop, dass ich da halt den Teil,
der mich angeht, da kann ich dran und der, der mich nicht angeht, eben nicht.
Aber, also okay, krass. Und gut, China zu dealisten ist einfach keine Beschwerde
in unserer Jurisdiktion.
Genau das. Und es scheint generell
zu sein, dass sie sich auf Länder konzentrieren, die weiter weg sind.
Auf der Blacklist selbst sind auch Taiwan zum Beispiel, manchmal auch Hongkong
zu finden, manchmal Korea, manchmal nicht, Südkorea.
Trotzdem haben wir Bestelldaten aus, ich sag mal, fast allen Ländern und aus
über 80 Ländern haben wir mehr als 100 Bestellungen.
Fuzhou, Chongqing.
Ja, ich wollte nur kurz mal rausfinden, wie die Stadt ausgesprochen wird.
Wie viele Leute wohnen da?
8,2 Millionen.
Also ihr Kleinstauern-Dorf.
Genau.
Also aus 80 Ländern dieses Planeten,
also ungefähr die Hälfte der Länder haben das schon mal bestellt.
Haben mehr als 100 Bestellungen.
Mehr als 100 Bestellungen. Ihr hattet auch eine Grafik angefertigt,
die konzentrieren sich aber auf Europa, USA.
Ja, auf Westeuropa und die USA. Die meisten Bestellungen gibt es aus Frankreich
mit knapp über 20% der Bestellungen und knapp unter 20% der Bestellungen kommen aus den USA.
Dann sind da Deutschland, Großbritannien noch groß dabei, die skandinavischen
Länder und ein bisschen weiter weg dann Australien.
So, jetzt sammeln, jetzt laufen
da so diese Shops, irgendwo wird es dann wahrscheinlich ein Modell geben.
Ich stelle mir jetzt vor, ich bin da Merchant. Also meine Aufgabe als Merchant
ist dann im Prinzip dafür zu sorgen, dass ich da coole Produkte drin habe.
Es gibt irgendwie so eine Standardbestückung des Stores, aber ich könnte mir
vorstellen, weil es ja viel Kleidung und Schuhe, das ist ja mindestens so ein saisonales Geschäft.
Das heißt, da müssen diese 25.000 zum gegebenen Zeitpunkt aktiven Stores ja
schon irgendwie auch immer, nicht alles so gnädig wie Doc Martens,
die seit vielen Jahrzehnten mit dem gleichen Schuh einfach antreten.
Genau. Auch hier gibt es wieder wunderbare Automatisierung.
Gelegentlich möchte man seine Produktpalette updaten und dazu gibt es dann Crawler,
wo man dann eine originale Webshop-Seite reinkippt und dann kommen Produktbilder,
Produktbeschreibung, Preise daraus.
Das kann man dann noch bearbeiten und in den eigenen Webshop überführen.
Okay.
Dann gab es, glaube ich, auch irgendwie so eine Art Business Analytics,
die man darüber gemacht hat, um zu gucken, welcher Shop jetzt oder welches Land.
Also wenn ich 25.000 Online-Shops habe, das ist ja wirklich… Ja.
Also es gibt eine ganze Menge Monitoring. Ich greife nochmal ein Thema zurück.
Wenn ich auf dieser Seite bestelle, dann bin ich auf irgendeiner Shop-Webseite.de.
Im Bezahlprozess werde ich dann aber in diesem zweiten Schritt auf eine andere
Seite weitergeleitet. Das heißt, ich habe eine gewisse Entkopplung zwischen
Bestellseite und Payment Gateway.
Und im Monitoring, im Backend kann ich für jede Domain und für jedes Payment
Gateway die Performance sehen.
Ich kann sehen, wie viele Bestellungen darüber gehen.
Ich kann wahrscheinlich auch sehen, wie erfolgreich die Bestellungen,
die Bezahlvorgänge sind.
Und wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel sehe, dass ein Payment Gateway geblockt wurde,
weil sich halt doch mal jemand beschwert hat, dann kann ich einfach dieses Payment
Gateway austauschen und muss nicht den ganzen Shop neu bauen durch diese Entkopplung.
Und das Payment Gateway wird dann auch einfach ausgerollt.
Wenn ich ein Payment Gateway habe auf das, was weiß ich, 20 Online-Shops laufen,
dann ändere ich das und die 20 Online-Shops werden automatisch umkonfiguriert,
jetzt auf das neue zu werfen?
Genau, das läuft über eine zentrale Payment-Gateway-API.
Also schon auch wirklich von Leuten, die ungefähr wissen, wie man sowas macht.
Die zum Glück nur ungefähr wissen, wie man sowas macht. Genau.
So, jetzt...
Kai schaut sich das an, teilt das mit Le Monde, teilt das mit Guardian.
Guardian spricht mit Betroffenen.
Kai schaut sich das Firmennetzwerk dahinter an.
Was passiert denn jetzt?
Gute Frage, sehr gute Frage. Wir haben vor wenigen Tagen beobachtet,
dass die allermeisten unserer 22.500 Domains, die Mitte April noch online waren, nicht mehr online sind.
Also die Domains gibt es noch, aber Cloudflare, das da einen schönen Hilfsdienst
erbringt, wirft eine Fehlermeldung und behauptet, der Server dahinter sei offline,
Domain kann nicht erreicht werden.
Ist der Server denn offline?
Der Server ist nicht offline. Unser Monitoring sagt, die Server sind alle noch erreichbar.
Also wir sind da jetzt nicht in 500 Servern drin, aber wir kennen eine ganze
Menge IPs und haben ein eigenes Monitoring aufgebaut, um vielleicht irgendwann
sagen zu können, oh, da macht jetzt vielleicht Strafverfolgung etwas.
Und wir können sehen, dass da gerade ganz viele Server abgeschaltet werden.
Aber bisher laufen zumindest die Server relativ unverändert weiter.
Nur bei den Domains scheint es gerade irgendwelche Probleme zu geben.
Wir können aber nur spekulieren.
Hat denn jemand Cloudflare Bescheid gesagt?
Wir wollten Cloudflare Bescheid sagen. Die haben auch ein schönes Formular.
Allerdings ist bei diesem Formular standardmäßig angehakt, dass auch der Webseitenbetreiber
informiert wird, wenn man eine Webseite meldet.
Und das wollen wir natürlich nicht. Deswegen sind wir auf anderen Wegen auf
Cloudflare zugegangen.
Aber seitens Cloudflare gab es da nicht so viel Interesse, das ohne dieses Formular zu machen.
Andere Wege auf Cloudflare? Behörden.
Genau, Behörden sind noch ein spannender Punkt.
Wir sind nicht erst letzte Woche auf Behörden zugegangen, sondern die Journalistin,
aber auch wir haben vor einiger Zeit schon gegenüber manchen Behörden angedeutet, hier,
wir könnten Infos teilen. Ja.
Da gab es erstmal nicht so viel Reaktion. Da ist erstmal nicht so viel passiert.
Scheint ja auch Kleinkriminalität zu sein. Also wenn man bestellt,
gehen 70 Euro Flöten, die dann im Zweifel sogar noch von der eigenen Bank erstattet werden.
Das heißt, der Schaden ist gar nicht bei den Leuten, die bestellen.
Insofern ist da lange nichts passiert und erst relativ kurz vor der Veröffentlichung
haben wir es nochmal geschafft, mit einer Behörde zu sprechen und auch unsere Infos zu teilen.
Aber wir wissen jetzt nicht, was genau diese Behörde plant, was sie tun wird,
ob sie schon etwas getan hat. Ich bin jedenfalls gespannt.
Möchtest du sagen, in welchem Land diese Behörde? Das ist keine deutsche.
Das ist keine Deutsche mit drei Buchstaben. Der erste Buchstabe ist ein F.
Also erstmal muss man glaube ich dieses Geschäftsmodell dann doch echt mal mit
Anerkennung auch irgendwie sehen,
weil du machst halt so ein Kleinstverbrechen, für das am Ende niemand irgendwie,
ja, also Kai Biermann ist natürlich irgendwie auch verärgert gewesen,
Aber das hat jetzt die Familie nicht in Notstand versetzt, dass er 40 Euro für
Doc Martens bezahlt hat.
Ich meine sogar, das könnte noch ein zweites Mal passiert sein.
Und aber, ne, das heißt, da gibt's dann irgendwie, ja, eine Medienkompetenzschulung
für die gesamte Familie beim Kauf von Schuhen oder so, ja,
aber der wird jetzt, der wird und in dem Fall, klar, ne, Kalbiermann,
Investigativjournalist, der beißt sich fest und,
legt diesen ganzen hängt diesen ganzen Laden draußen zum Trocknen auf, ja, aber ähm.
Die meisten Leute werden sich vielleicht ärgern, sind aber in ihrer,
werden nicht so viel Energie aufbringen.
Und wenn du jetzt bei irgendwie bei der Dorfpolizei auftrittst und sagst,
ich habe hier eine Regenjacke für 70 Euro bestellt, die ist nicht gekommen,
dann sagen die im Zweifelsfall, ja, hatte ich auch schon mal, warte mal noch.
Es gibt einfach überhaupt keinen Strafverfolgungsdruck irgendwo,
der groß ist. Und dann kannst du das Ding auf Millionen skalieren.
Du brauchst halt nur 25.000 Online-Shops.
Ich muss schon sagen, dass ich da Anerkennung für habe, dass man das so hochzieht.
Ja, die Frage, wen das interessiert, ist eine gute Frage.
Also Strafverfolgung inzwischen hoffentlich ein bisschen.
Dann wird da Infrastruktur von Google, Cloudflare, Stripe, PayPal relativ direkt genutzt.
Und bei der Suchmaschine kann es sogar sein, dass da noch Geld bezahlt wird
von dieser Gruppe, um Werbung zu platzieren.
Das heißt, auch Google hat vielleicht gar nicht das allergrößte Interesse,
da sofort tätig zu werden. Außerdem ist es ja immer doof, wenn man Domains zensiert.
Cloudflare ja, hat sich geäußert hat kein Interesse bei Stripe war es bisher
schwierig Kontakt herzustellen ebenso Paypal und.
Stripe wahrscheinlich nicht so bekannt oder vielleicht nicht allen Hörerinnen
bekannt ist ein Payment Abwechslungsanbieter ich glaube einer der größten vielleicht
sogar der größte vor allem.
Der beste also der wirklich funktioniert Funktioniert, so.
Ja, die dementsprechend auch eine große Bedeutung haben. Also wird die von sehr
vielen Webseiten benutzt. So Wirecard quasi.
Wirecard in echt.
Schwieriger Vergleich. Dann auch die Meta-Ebene benutzen.
Thrive ist in Ordnung, lass Thrive in Ruhe.
Ich wundere mich aber, dass die da nicht so empfänglich sind,
weil das sollte ja nun eigentlich sehr in ihrem Interesse sein,
aber keine Ahnung, was da so läuft.
Es ist schwierig, glaube ich, die richtige Person ranzukriegen,
weil First Level Support legt einfach auf.
Ich habe das zur Zeit des Bundesverdienstcoins einmal ausprobiert,
da hatte ich 5000 Kreditkartendatensätze.
Und wenn du dann bei so einer Meldestelle in den USA anrufst und sagst,
du hast hier 5000 Kreditkartennummern, du möchtest die gerne loswerden,
die nehmen dich nicht ernst.
Und insofern funktioniert das einfach nur.
I am a proud holder of the German Bundesverdienstcoin. Vielleicht.
Genau.
Aber 5000 ist ja verhältnismäßig wenig, wenn man jetzt so übliche Datenlecks anschaut.
Also ein Online-Shop wird oder ein Leak ist gerne mal größer.
Aber okay, die glauben dir nicht. Es gibt dann noch also ich meine am Ende sollte
doch eigentlich derjenige Interesse daran haben, der den wirklichen Schaden hat.
Also neben der Person, deren Geld weg ist. Jetzt hast du aber gesagt,
die kriegen das potenziell von ihrer Bank zurück.
Wo ich auch überrascht wäre, dass die Banken das tun.
Aber wo in der Kette, wo sind denn jetzt, wo entsteht der, also ich würde sagen,
größtenteils bei den Opfern entsteht der finanzielle Schaden.
Dann vielleicht bei den Leuten, die denen Kreditkarten geben,
also die Banken, kartenausgebenden Institute.
Aber da ist es wahrscheinlich einfach schon viel zu divers, weil die über so
und so viele Länder so und so viele Opfer haben, sodass bei denen kein ausreichend
großer Leidensdruck entsteht.
Offenbar. Also Mastercard und Visa selbst wird es nicht interessieren.
Die verdienen mit neuen Karten wahrscheinlich sogar Geld.
Und der Schaden ist dann zum Teil sicherlich bei den Banken, die das Geld erstatten.
Wenn ich mich an die Wände und sage, hey, meine Kreditkartendaten gingen verloren,
da wurde was abgebucht, dann gibt es ja das Geld in der Regel relativ unkompliziert zurück.
Das heißt, ein nennenswerter Teil des Schadens ist bei den Banken,
aber es sind sehr, sehr viele Banken in sehr, sehr vielen Ländern.
Das heißt, die einzelne Bank hat wieder nur einen relativ kleinen Schaden.
Und macht man jetzt wegen 25.000 Euro da so einen großen Topf auf?
Genial. Lass uns das auch machen. Bei dieser Gelegenheit wollte ich nochmal
empfehlen, LMP-Shirts könnt ihr bestellen.
Es gibt da so einen schönen Begriff in der Bankenwelt, den fand ich schon immer
cool. Rentable Sicherheit.
Also man macht das halt so sicher.
Wie es sich rentiert. Also wenn halt irgendwie das Aussitzen von Credit Card
Fraud weniger Geld kostet, als irgendwas zu unternehmen, so,
dann wird halt ausgesessen.
Das ist eine reine Kosten-Nutzen-Analyse.
Und es ist ja auch tatsächlich, du sagst das immer so, als wäre das zynisch oder falsch.
Du kaufst doch auch nur ein Fahrradschloss, was auf jeden Fall weniger als das Fahrrad kostet.
Wann klang das jetzt so zynisch?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich wollte nur diesen Begriff mal einfach in den Raum werfen,
dass der halt so existiert.
In gewisser Hinsicht ist er ja auch nachvollziehbar.
Nur der potenzielle Schaden hier ist ja, dass sozusagen solche kriminellen Aktivitäten
nicht runtergefahren werden.
Obwohl man ja im Prinzip das sehr gut belegen kann. Ich meine,
warum lehnen die dich mit 5000 Kreditkarten ab, weil sie dir nicht glauben?
Du kannst sie ja hochladen, dann können sie es ja selber überprüfen.
Du kannst aber in das Beschwerdefeld nur 4000 Zeichen eingeben.
Ja gut, aber ich meine, da könnte man ja auch einen anderen Vorgang für vorsehen.
Da haben die dann einen Captcha, wenn du jetzt da anfängst.
Aber du bist ja ein Roboter. Tja, naja, also auf jeden Fall ist hier noch einiges
zu optimieren in diesen ganzen Meldungsprozessen.
Ich kann mir vielleicht ein bisschen außen vor gehalten.
Ich glaube schon, dass ein größerer Teil der Leute, die halt irgendwie aktuelle
Mode bestellen, potenziell auch jünger sind und nicht so hohe Einkommen haben
und es für die dann vielleicht doch schon ein Treffer ist,
wenn sie da mal um 40 Euro oder 70 Euro verarscht werden, oder?
Sicherlich, also es gibt genug Leute in Deutschland, die nicht so viel Geld verdienen.
Oder genau umso nicht.
Aber, also die Daten, die wir gesehen haben, zeigen schon eher,
dass längst nicht alle ihr Geld tatsächlich verlieren.
Die verlieren aber immer ihre Daten.
Und auch das kann ja schmerzhaft sein.
Wir wissen immer noch nicht, was jetzt alles im Hintergrund mit diesen Daten
noch passiert. Es kann ja auch sein, dass diese Kreditkartendaten erst ein halbes
Jahr später nochmal genutzt werden und dann richtig.
Und da kann es dann wehtun, wenn mehrere tausend Euro vorübergehend nicht verfügbar
sind, auch wenn sie irgendwann erstattet werden.
So, jetzt also Google hat kein wirkliches Interesse, Cloudflare hat kein wirkliches
Interesse, bei Stripe sind sie auch nicht aufgesprungen, PayPal nicht, die Banken nicht.
Weitermachen.
Jupp, keinen.
Die Verbraucherzentrale hat einen Fake-Shop-Finder.
Genau, die interessiert es. Wir haben unsere Daten abgegeben und vielleicht
sind unsere Domains dann auch bald im Fake-Shop-Finder von der Verbraucherzentrale
geblacklistet, falls das nicht schon passiert ist.
Ich hätte halt jetzt gedacht, okay, haben die beispielsweise eine Blacklist,
die ich dann in meinen DNS-Server einbauen kann, also in meinen, wie heißt das denn hier,
der DNS-Server, den eigentlich alle haben, ich will jetzt RetroPie heißen,
aber der heißt ja Piehole, genau. Genau.
Pi holt den klassischen hier DNS-Server, den man sich zu Hause hinstellt,
mit Werbeblocken. Dann könnte ich ja auch mal die ganzen Fake-Shops dazu packen.
Vermutlich verkaufen die einfach auch keine Produkte, wo ich Gefahr laufe, dass ich sie kaufe.
Ich glaube nicht, dass die Verbraucherzentrale da ihre Blacklist teilt,
aber wir können unsere Daten der Verbraucherzentrale geben.
Okay, aber wir könnten auch einfach das Ding auf GitHub hauen,
in dem Format, für eine Host-File und dann...
Genau, wir müssen halt schauen, also viele der Domains werden heute nicht mehr
benutzt, das heißt wir müssen auch irgendwie differenzieren zwischen Domains,
die früher genutzt wurden, wo heute vielleicht was anderes ist.
Oder wo jetzt schon wieder jemand anders einen Fake-Shop hat,
das sind dann gar nicht mehr die, sondern die Konkurrenz.
Ja, was war der Moment, den du am beeindruckendsten fandest?
Du hast jetzt sich viele Monate on and off damit auseinandergesetzt.
Also es gab zwei Momente. Einmal der Schritt von, es ist ein Webshop mit einem
Datenleck zu, es sind 10.000 Webshops mit 10.000 Datenlecks und das war krass.
So richtig beeindruckend war dann der erste Blick hinter die Kulissen,
als wir dann langsam verstanden haben,
wie da wo welche Punkte zusammenlaufen und dass das nicht viele Akteure sind,
die alle das gleiche machen, sondern wir können alle 75.000 Domains einem Netzwerk zuordnen.
Und dann dahinter die Orchestrierung, die dafür sorgt, dass diese Webshops sich
alle gleich sind und zentral gesteuert werden.
Auf einem Server hattest du glaube ich gesagt so 200 Webshops teilweise auf einem?
Genau, in der Regel 200 Webshops per Server, auch über 100 IP-Adressen per Server,
auch das kostet wieder Geld.
Ui.
Machen sie vielleicht.
Warum mache ich denn unterschiedliche IP-Adressen auf den Server?
Brauche ich doch heutzutage gar nicht mehr.
Also ich könnte ja entsprechend...
Auch mit TLS problemlos alle auf der gleichen IP laufen lassen.
Zumal das eh alles hinter Cloudflare läuft. Aber vielleicht ist es in Bezug
auf Suchmaschinen Optimierung, wenn da noch bestimmte Webshops unter verschiedenen
IPv4-Netzen erreichbar sind.
Okay. Gut, die werden sicherlich kein Geld verschwendet haben.
Und dann, als du gesehen hast, wie viel Kohle die damit machen?
Ja, das ist spannend. Das bleibt spannend. Wir haben kein vollständiges Bild.
Wir konnten mal einen Blick in so ein Kreditkartendaten-Backend schmeißen und
dann war da ein Konto, wo 300.000 US-Dollar rumliegen.
Sehe ich nicht jeden Tag auf meinem Konto.
Dann Das liegt daran.
Dass du online so viel bestellst.
Nicht jeden Tag. Siehst du das auf deinem Konto? Wie viele Tage siehst du denn das auf deinem Konto?
Du überweist es immer schnell, woanders hin.
Genau, das geht dann über drei, vier Länder.
Bei Stripe haben wir sehr konkrete Zahlen zwischen November 23 2023 und April
2024 wurden da knapp 300.000 US-Dollar rausgetragen,
also von den Stripe-Konten auf andere Stripe-Konten transferiert.
Das heißt, das ist mal so ein Zeitraum, wo wir wissen, über Stripe haben die
innerhalb von unter einem halben Jahr 300.000 gemacht und das ist jetzt nicht der Hauptkanal.
Und es ist auch nach wie vor so, dass wir sicherlich nicht Einblick in alles haben.
Das heißt, alles, was wir hier an Zahlen haben, sind prinzipiell untere Grenzen.
Und hast du dir da mal irgendwie Gedanken drüber gemacht, dass du da jetzt die
ganzen armen chinesischen Webdeveloper, die davon bezahlt werden,
dass du denen jetzt Probleme machst? Hast du da gar kein Gewissen?
Ja, ich habe mir Gedanken darüber gemacht. Ich hatte mit den Biometriegeräten
vor ein, zwei Jahren die Gedanken, möchte ich jetzt noch in die USA reisen und
jetzt mache ich mir Gedanken.
Möchte ich jetzt noch nach China reisen? Weiß ich nicht. Das war so der primäre Gedanke dabei.
Das legt sich. Also es gibt einfach viele schöne andere Länder.
Seitdem ich nicht mehr in die USA reise, habe ich so viele tolle andere Länder
kennengelernt. Das ist schon in Ordnung.
Türkei bereise ich auch nicht mehr. Da gibt es tolle, Griechenland zum Beispiel.
Okay. Ja, eine spannende Sache.
Ich glaube, wir müssen noch eine Offenlegung machen.
Man muss das an so einer Stelle, eine Offenlegung machen. Ja, das wäre ganz gut.
Ich habe nichts damit zu tun.
Tim hat nichts damit zu tun, ich schon. Wir haben eigentlich seitdem Kantorkel
da dran ist, ist natürlich sowieso drüber geredet.
Ich habe aber jetzt keine nennenswerten Beiträge geleistet, außer klugen Rat.
Besonders klugen Rat eigentlich. Immer.
Und wir arbeiten zusammen. Das wurde auch von unserem Arbeitgeber oder von unserer
Firma entsprechend veröffentlicht.
Genau.
Ich möchte aber ergänzen, dass ich auch sehr, sehr viele Nächte reingesteckt
habe, die nicht Arbeitszeit waren.
Das ist dein Problem, wenn du dir die Arbeitszeit nicht wiederholst.
Ne, klar, sowas macht man natürlich nicht wirklich im 9-to-5-Ding und allein
schon auf dem Camp hatten wir ja auch Urlaub.
Aber solche Dinge macht man natürlich auch aus dem Antrieb, der über,
was weiß ich, dass es mein Job hinausgeht.
Ja, eine Nacht war besonders.
Wir sind da von Datenleck zu Datenleck gesprungen und haben so ein paar mehr
Dinge erkannt und dann war es plötzlich 5 Uhr morgens und dann haben wir mal
gesagt, wir sollten mal abbrechen für heute.
Aber es ist uns wirklich schwer gefallen, da mitten in der Nacht oder am frühen Morgen aufzuhören.
Wir hätten gerne noch einige Tage einfach durchgezogen.
Was ist denn so dein Antrieb?
Was reizt dich denn da dran? Was ist denn so dein inneres Belohnungssystem?
Weil bezahlt worden bist du dafür ja jetzt in dem Sinne nicht.
Erstmal ist es interessant. Also technisch ist es völlig langweilig.
Wir gucken in Datenlags, Daten, die irgendwo erstmal rumliegen,
wo man nichts klassisch hacken muss, wo man keine Sicherheitslücke ausnutzen muss.
Aber das, was dahinter steckt, ist oft genug einfach mega interessant und manchmal
muss man dann im weiteren Verfahren auch richtig Sicherheitslücken ausnutzen
oder erstmal finden und das ist natürlich dann auch eine gewisse Art von Sport.
So schaffe ich es, dahinter zu kommen und da reinzugucken?
In erster Linie Neugierde. Also es wäre jetzt im Nachhinein natürlich schön,
wenn Strafverfolgungsbehörden tätig werden und dieses Netzwerk zumindest bremsen.
Aber es war mit Sicherheit nicht so, dass ich gesagt habe, ich sehe hier jetzt
einen Fake-Web-Shop und ich möchte die auseinandernehmen, sondern ich war einfach
neugierig und blieb dann da über ein Jahr lang immer mal wieder dran.
Und das finde ich ja auch ganz spannend, dass du diese Informationen,
die du jetzt mehr oder weniger chronologisch, so wie sie im Kontext sind,
wiedergibst, die hast du ja zusammen mit deinem Team über die Zeit nach und nach entdeckt.
Das war ja nicht am ersten Tag auf einmal klar, sondern ganz im Gegenteil.
Am Anfang war nur, es gibt Online-Shops, ja okay.
Aber wir waren ja soweit, dass wir das Projekt fast aufgegeben haben.
Alright Dann sind wir eigentlich durch soweit, können wir jetzt den Bollerwagen
vollladen und endlich losziehen Jetzt.
Geht's an den See.
Ein bisschen rumpaulen, wie
man das so macht heute. Naja, ich gehe jetzt erstmal ans Schneidegerät.
Ich gehe arbeiten.
Man muss jetzt nachsitzen, weil du so viel Privatsport betrieben hast.
Nee, es war, also tatsächlich, ich habe ja am Anfang schon gesagt,
dass wir mit diesen Feiertagen durcheinander gekommen sind.
Und es war bei dieser Veröffentlichung auch eines der Themen,
dass Kai Biermann der festen Überzeugung war dass der 9.
Mai in Berlin ja kein Feiertag ist oder nee, nur in Berlin ein Feiertag ist,
weil das der Kampftag der Frauen ist und den anderen nicht machen und deswegen die Zeit am 9.
Mai natürlich erscheint und dann kurzfristig so sagt er so was ich noch sagen
wollte die erscheint doch am 8.
Die Print, das ist ja ein Printzeit ganzseitig Artikel und dann durften Le Monde
und Guardian sagen, ja okay, dann schreiben wir es schneller,
um das früher zu machen und Matthias hat sich einen schönen Call auf heute 15
Uhr gelegt, weil es ja kein Feiertag ist.
Oh Mann, ey.
Zu spät gesehen. Ja.
So, vielen Dank, Kantorkel, für die Ausführung, für deinen dokumentierten Hacksport.
Nein, Obtain. Achso, wir haben das gar nicht aufgeklärt.
Obtainerism.
Warum wir die ganze Zeit Obtained sagen?
Weil wir haben die ja nicht gehackt. Und in dem Zeitartikel steht dann zum Beispiel
drin so ein größeres Datenleck, das Zeit einsehen konnte.
Wir haben die Daten. Und im Guardian-Artikel steht, Security Research Labs and
IT Security Consultancy, who obtained gigabytes of data.
Und dieses obtained finde ich halt sehr schön, weil, ja, obtained.
Das würdest du wie übersetzen in dem Zusammenhang?
In dem Besitz gekommen sind.
Gar nicht beabsichtigt.
Ja, zugefallen ist es. Obtained. Wo hast du das her? Obtained. Ja.
Und das finde ich... Ja, ich hab den Obtained.
Jetzt muss ich mir doch noch mal anschauen, was so für Übersetzungsoptionen...
Erhalten, Erlangen, Erlangen.
Besorgen, abrufen, erwirtschaften, bekommen, akquirieren.
Bekommen. Obtänt.
Ich hab das nicht geklaut, ich hab das akquiriert.
Wie kommt dieses Gras?
Ich bin kein Dieb, ich bin in der Akquise tätig.
Woher haben Sie den Gras in Ihrer Tasche? Den hab ich obtained. Den hab ich obtained.
Oh Mann.
Ja genau, aber deswegen ist für mich auf jeden Fall seit dem Release gestern
von des Guardians Articles, ich freue mich, dass ich das Ding einfach nur obtain.
Okay.
Can we obtain access to this box? I obtained data.
Gut, Schluss jetzt mit dem Wortwitz hier. Das wird das alles wieder zu albern.
Das ist ein ernstes Magazin hier, was wir hier produzieren.
Sagen wir tschüss?
Tschüss.
Vielen Dank, schönen Vatertag.
Genau. Oder was er sonst noch so feiert. Bis bald.
Ciao, ciao.
Tschüss.